this morning in our series pushing the
limits we feature an especially brave
runner taking part in this year's
Running of the Bulls festival in Spain
more than 2,000 people ran this morning
in the famous and dangerous annual event
in Pamplona well it dates back more than
700 years when Bulls were reared for
fighting and ran through the city to
reach the bullring towns people would
jump in their paths as a show of bravery
now retired US Army Major Ivan Castro is
taking this high risk tradition to a new
level
Castro survived a deadly attack while
serving in Iraq and we've been following
Castro story for five years we last saw
him in 2016 as a part of Prince Harry's
Invictus games and as Jonathan Vigliotti
reports from Pamplona
he's redefining what it means to come
back after injury we were among those
who go running with the Bulls early this
morning hence this traditional red and
white uniform we came all of this way to
meet one man major Ivan Castro who I
think it's safe to say is unlike any
other person to run down this street
before
a thousand-pound enemy charging the
frontline writer Ernest Hemingway once
compared pantalones Running of the Bulls
to a battlefield which means for the
first time since 2006 major Ivan Castro
former US Special Forces went back to a
war zone it's like it is like a mission
and and it is a battlefield for me you
know I don't know when this thing is
coming I got to rely on the eyes of
others relying on the eyes of others
because Ivan is about to run with the
Bulls blind do people ever say you're
blind you're crazy for doing this yeah I
hear it all the time
and what do you say to them life is too
short
Ivan was deployed in Iraq in 2006 when
his team came under a mortar attack two
of his brothers in arms' were killed the
blast caused Ivan to lose complete
vision in both eyes not being able to
deploy not be able to jump out of planes
no more the way I did before I missed
and I missed an excitement that
gentleman and I think that every year I
need something to do to stay focused the
training to train in order to feel alive
you know so he trained for marathons at
first then ultramarathons
he journeyed to the South Pole with
Prince Harry climbed Mount Kilimanjaro
and just finished the El Camino de
Santiago a 400 mile long pilgrimage
across Spain
we arrived just in time for pantalones
San Fermin festival the week-long
non-stop celebration of life and death
for some it's a coming-of-age for others
a tested tradition for Ivan it's a
second chance to outrun danger ring a
marathon you just put one foot in front
of the other and don't quit and
eventually you'll press the finish line
but I think the finish line is here is
not getting bored you know and with the
opening of the gates the battle begins
he was swallowed by the frenzy but as
others tumbled like bowling pins
Ivan stood his ground he's guided
through the darkness by his friends cred
damar and David Kiser
you can hear the Bulls go by like just
just swiped by you and then you can hear
the people as well as like the panic and
the panic and fear and people just
running in fear and total fare and being
blind
you just don't know it's coming as he is
that bull like right behind me or is he
five five feet is he an age we gotta go
in the end he escaped from the half mile
sprint uninjured with the balls has this
experience tell you something new about
yourself there's nothing there's nothing
impossible
a soldier battling back and grabbing
life by the horns
the bull run will continue for the rest
of the week but Ivan says he's done
pushing his limits and luck for now he
hopes his next chance will take him all
the way to the North Pole for CBS this
morning Jonathan Vigliotti Pamplona oh
wow that's such a great story I've met
Ivan Castro twice and the last time he
just showed up at the Invictus games
when I was interviewing Prince Harry and
Prince Harry went over gave him a big
bear hug and said what dude why are you
wearing a pink shirt now Ivan was not
wearing a pink shirt but he's blind and
the two chuckled and I thought how funny
that and you know what Prince Harry has
such a close authentic relationship with
wounded servicemen and Ivan gives so
much inspiration to other people who've
been wounded that you can do anything
look at him so you're not surprised to
see him out there I am NOT I'm sorry but
he is awesome he is just an awesome guy
careful Jonathan Vigliotti you too